[Aplausos]
[Música]
francia es el único país que hace que
hasta los argentinos parezcan gente
humilde el ego de los franceses es tan
superlativo que ni siquiera cabe dentro
de las fronteras del país y eso explica
que en el siglo 19
francia se dedicará a colonizar otros
países
casi la paz de áfrica fue una colonia
francesa y de hecho a que no adivinan es
cuál es la lengua más hablada en el
áfrica sub-sahariana exacto el francés
pero no sólo eso seguro que todos
habréis oído decir que américa latina es
el patio trasero de eeuu verdad pues
bien áfrica es el patio trasero de
francia por ejemplo en el año 2011
francia lideró todas las operaciones
militares contra gadafi
dos años más tarde el gobierno de
françois hollande envió tropas para
defender al presidente de la república
centroafricana al mismo tiempo los
soldados franceses también estaban
luchando contra los terroristas
islámicos en mali
básicamente el ejército francés ha
estado presente en prácticamente todos
los conflictos armados que se han
producido en áfrica para que os hagáis
una idea francia controla incluso la
divisa que se utiliza en muchos países
africanos
[Música]
en otras palabras que aunque hace
décadas que los países africanos se
independizaron francia todavía mantiene
una influencia brutal sobre sus
gobiernos podeis llamarlo poder blando
diplomacia o simplemente colonialismo
2.0 y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
muchos seguro que francia se está
haciendo rica con las colonias africanas
verdad pues mis queridos amigos de
visual política nada más lejos de la
realidad
en los últimos diez años el comercio de
francia con áfrica ha bajado de un 10 a
un 47 por ciento tal cual como lo oís
aunque francia domina la política
africana la economía es otra historia
totalmente distinta de hecho tras siglos
de colonialismo y neocolonialismo los
países africanos apenas han evolucionado
apenas hay empresas nuevas que hayan
surgido gracias a la inversión francesa
y mientras tanto francia se gasta miles
de millones de euros todos los años en
mantener su cuota de influencia en el
continente aunque a la hora de la verdad
apenas consigan sacarla ningún beneficio
y ya que no adivina jce quien si está
exprimiendo al máximo la colaboración
con áfrica
exacto estamos hablando de
las empresas chinas y áfrica se
necesitan el uno al otro más que nunca
desde los últimos diez años la inversión
china ha cambiado el skyline de casi
todas las ciudades africanas algunos
países como etiopía se están
convirtiendo en potencias industriales
sobre todo en el sector textil las
empresas chinas no sólo están
aprovechando la mano de obra barata sino
que además han encontrado un nuevo
mercado en el que vender sus productos
[Música]
tal cual como lo oís los móviles chinos
están arrasando en áfrica y cada vez más
gente está aprendiendo el idioma de
confucio en lugar del de molière en
otras palabras que mientras francia
manda soldados china manda hombres de
negocios y parece que les está
funcionando bastante bien así que la
pregunta es por qué francia no ha sabido
capitalizar su influencia en áfrica y
que puede hacer el nuevo presidente
francés emmanuel macrón para mejorar
esta situación hoy vamos a responder a
esta pregunta pero antes vamos a ver un
poco de historia
desventajas del paternalismo los que
seáis veteranos seguidores de visual
política ya sabéis que tras la segunda
guerra mundial todos los países
africanos se independizaron de sus
colonizadores
[Música]
pero no os equivoquéis no todos los
colonizadores se comportaron de la misma
forma por ejemplo españa tenía dos
colonias en áfrica el sáhara y guinea
ecuatorial cuando estos dos países
quisieron independizarse el gobierno de
españa' dijo algo así como la verdad tío
pero de veras teníamos dos colonias en
áfrica bueno pues que bastante tenemos
con lo que tenemos por aquí con italia
pasó algo muy parecido habían invadido
etiopía durante la época de mussolini y
tampoco estaban en condiciones de oponer
mucha resistencia a la descolonización
sin embargo el caso de francia era muy
distinto por aquella época el presidente
francés era este señor que veis en
pantalla que se llamaba charles de
gaulle charles de gaulle era como lo
podríamos definir algo así como donald
trump pero con cerebro
francia no podría ser francia sin su
grandeza charles de gaulle por un lado a
de gaulle no le quedó otro remedio que
permitir que las colonias africanas se
independizaran pensar que en mantener
colonias es un negocio muy caro y
francia tenía bastante con reconstruirse
pero como os podéis imaginar un gobierno
con tantísimo ego no iba a permitir que
sus antiguas posesiones se marcharán del
todo así que francia mantuvo su ejército
en todas sus antiguas colonias
[Música]
y desde el palacio del elíseo se
dedicaron a apoyar a todas las élites
políticas que empezaban a gobernar estos
nuevos países africanos por ejemplo en
el año 1964 el ejército francés apoyó un
golpe de estado en gabón desde entonces
gabón estuvo gobernado por la dictadura
de omar bongo durante más de 40 años y
quien diría es que le suministraba todas
las armas
efectivamente francia a cambio davon
sigue a rajatabla la política exterior
francesa y es su principal suministrador
de uranio como sabéis francia es uno de
los países con más centrales nucleares
del mundo pues bien el uranio que
utilizan viene casi al cien por cien de
gabón y por supuesto a precio de amigos
[Música]
francia sin gabón sería como un coche
sin combustible
omar bongo presidente de gabón durante
42 años y lo mismo ocurre con otros
países como costa de marfil cuyo
presidente también está puesto manu
militari por francia desde el año 2011
el anterior salió del palacio
presidencial a cañonazos y ya os podéis
imaginar quién apretaba el gatillo
efectivamente los soldados franceses a
cambio costa de marfil es el principal
suministrador de café y cacao de francia
para que os hagáis una idea la
influencia francesa en esta región es
tan brutal que hasta la moneda que
utilizan está controlada por francia tal
cual como lo oís veréis el llamado
franco cf a es la moneda que se utiliza
en 15 países de áfrica occidental como
pueden ser mali burkina faso o costa de
marfil
pues bien resulta que el banco central
esta divisa está obligado a guardar al
menos la mitad de sus reservas de divisa
extranjera en el tesoro francés y desde
su creación el franco cf a está ligado a
la divisa francesa antes era el franco
francés y ahora es el euro
es decir que cuando el euro sube o baja
de valor el franco efe a réplica los
mismos movimientos pero esperad un
momento porque hay una letra pequeña y
esa letra es la economía productiva en
otras palabras francia ha estado
dirigiendo la política de sus antiguas
colonias durante décadas pero estos
países han seguido siendo igual de
pobres que cuando se independizaron con
la excepción de costa de marfil los
países de la francofonía africana siguen
siendo economías subdesarrolladas
agrícolas y prácticamente estancadas
ninguna empresa francesa se ha molestado
en abrir fábricas en áfrica y el dinero
que llegaba desde el elíseo se invertía
en armas o en extraer recursos naturales
nada más a fin de cuentas quien quiere
hacer negocios en áfrica pues mis
queridos amigos de visual política creo
que ya sabéis la respuesta
[Música]
os lo hemos dicho mil veces aquí en
visual político
hoy día china es el principal socio
comercial de áfrica desde los años 90
china empezó a crecer económicamente
como si no existiera mañana y cuando uno
se pone a crecer necesita recursos hasta
aquí nada nuevo bajo el sol pero a
diferencia de francia o cualquier otra
potencia occidental china se dio cuenta
enseguida de que áfrica era algo más que
minas o yacimientos petrolíferos a pili
al frío que áfrica va a convertirse en
la nueva planta manufacturera del mundo
de una dieta y la pobreza no será una
maldición y millones de personas en
áfrica escaparan de la pobreza
la mujer a la que acabáis de escuchar se
llama helen hai y es una empresaria
china su compañía se llama william y se
dedica a fabricar zapatos para grandes
marcas
si tenéis algunos zapatos de marca guess
o calvin klein es muy probable que estén
hechos por esta empresa ya que no
adivináis donde tienen una de sus
mayores fábricas pues nada más y nada
menos que nadie abeba la capital de
etiopía pensadlo bien en los años 90
china era la meca de la mano de obra
barata todas las grandes empresas
estadounidenses o europeas montaban sus
fábricas en ciudades como shenzhen o
guangzhou
[Música]
pero a medida que el país crece los
sueldos también crecen y para el año
helen hai se dio cuenta de que si quería
ahorrar costes en salarios tenía que
buscarse otro país ese país era etiopía
pero no sólo eso helen hai no viajaba
sola tenía el apoyo del gobierno chino
que se dirigió a las élites políticas
etíopes y les dijo mira chicos si nos
dejáis hacer las cosas a nuestra manera
podemos cubrir el país de fábricas
dinero y trabajos y como sabemos decir
por aquí dicho y hecho
[Música]
el parque industrial de hawassa ya está
operativo y etiopía quiere que se
convierta en un hub manufacturero pero
no sólo hablamos de etiopía podemos
encontrar fábricas chinas por muchos
otros países africanos whiteford es una
empresa que fabrica azulejos de cerámica
y su principal planta está en las
afueras de nairobi en kenia y podemos
encontrar nuevos parques industriales en
otros países como ghana y aunque las
empresas chinas estén apoyadas por el
gobierno hablamos en casi todos los
casos de inversión privada
[Música]
y ya sé lo que estáis pensando que todas
estas empresas se dedican a fabricar
cosas baratas para venderlas en los
países ricos verdad pues nada de eso por
ejemplo start times es una empresa en
tanzania con capital chino que se dedica
a dar televisión por cable desde que
llegaron al mercado los precios de la
televisión por cable han bajado en un
90%
gracias a eso más de 10 millones de
africanos pueden disfrutar de un
servicio que antes era un lujo para unos
pocos y lo mismo ocurre con las
telecomunicaciones empresas como huawei
han inundado el mercado con teléfonos
móviles baratos de hecho hoy en día los
keniatas usan el móvil al mismo nivel
que los europeos y por supuesto para
conectar todos estos centros
industriales el gobierno chino no ha
escatimado en dinero
[Música]
recordáis la nueva ruta de la seda el
llamado proyecto one by one road que ha
puesto en marcha el presidente chino xi
jinping pues también pasa por áfrica y
hablamos de miles de kilómetros de
ferrocarriles y carreteras que han
cambiado de arriba a abajo el paisaje de
muchas zonas de áfrica en otras palabras
que a diferencia de francia china no ha
intentado colonizar áfrica sino que les
ha convertido en socios comerciales
[Música]
y eso han conseguido ganar mucho más
dinero y más influencia
los institutos confucio están criando
generaciones de hablantes de mandarín
con mentalidad pro china en todo áfrica
y ahora os estaréis preguntando que
puede hacer francia al respecto para
quedarse de brazos cruzados mientras
china les come el mercado ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Música]
intereses comunes creo que no os vais a
sorprender si os digo que buena parte de
los países africanos no son precisamente
paraísos de seguridad jurídica y respeto
por la ley en muchos casos hablamos de
dictaduras en otros de estados fallidos
que a duras penas pueden contener las
peleas de distintas tribus
[Música]
eso significa que montar una fábrica en
un país como gabón es bastante más
complicado que en eeuu por poner un
ejemplo
no basta con comprar unos terrenos y
conseguir un permiso sino que hay que
tener contactos en el gobierno es decir
que la diplomacia en estos casos juega
un papel fundamental recordáis que se
había dicho que francia controla con
mano de hierro a los gobiernos de sus
antiguas colonias pues creo que ya
podéis adivinar el resto de la historia
[Música]
[Aplausos]
las empresas francesas tienen que estar
a la ofensiva y luchar contra la
influencia de la rival china en los cada
vez más competitivos mercados de áfrica
estas son las palabras del ministro de
finanzas francés pierre moscovici como
os podéis imaginar si francia no quiere
que china invierta en sus ex colonias y
en herramientas suficientes para
evitarlo y por eso el dinero chino
apenas ha llegado a estos países por
supuesto que beijing ha pagado algunos
proyectos en países como costa de marfil
o gabón pero muy poca cosa si lo
comparamos con la inversión en etiopía o
en kenia sin embargo las cosas podrían
empezar a cambiar el nuevo presidente de
francia
enmanuel macrón ha prometido dar un giro
de 180 grados en lo que se refiere a
áfrica y parece que ya ha pasado a la
acción
patrón resucita su asociación con china
en áfrica tal cual dijo macros en la
rueda de prensa china tiene el dinero y
nosotros el conocimiento de la región en
otras palabras que francia estaría
dispuesta a permitir que los políticos
africanos a los que controlan acepten la
inversión china ahora bien ellos quieren
un trozo del pastel por supuesto esta
noticia es de enero de 2018 y todavía
queda mucho para ver cómo llegará a
ponerse en práctica este acuerdo
[Música]
así que ahora la pregunta es es que
áfrica cambiará su política con áfrica y
empezará a tratar a sus antiguas
colonias como socios comerciales o se
quedará todo en buenas palabras pensáis
que esto puede ser un nuevo empujón para
que áfrica salga de la pobreza antes
incluso de lo que nos podríamos imaginar
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios mientras tanto si queréis
saber como áfrica está dejando atrás la
pobreza hacer clic en este otro vídeo y
como siempre no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribirse a visual polític para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like compartirlo con
vuestros amigos y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]
[Aplausos]